[Musique]
joyeux noël et à très bientôt
tu sais ce concours de pâtisserie de
noël dont tu parle tout le temps ah
ouais comité de sélection de belgravia
est heureux de vous inviter à notre
concours international de pâtisserie
noël incroyable mais vrai c'est qu'elle
soit honnête
noël est vraiment une période machine
j'aimerais juste avoir quelqu'un avec
qui il pas mes voeux de noël se réalise
toujours
[Musique]
je suis vraiment désolé ce n'est rien
pas de problème
tiède voulait dit margaret de la cour
duchesse de monteynard je suis stacy de
nos voix je pense que nous étions
destinés à me rencontrer
je suis censé épousé le prince édouard
le jour de l'an je déteste être sous les
projecteurs tout ce que je voulais au
départ et c'était vivre une vie normale
je veux que nous échangions nous et nous
échangions nos fins je veux devenir vous
et que vous deveniez mois sérieux vous
aurez uniquement pendant deux jours
personne ne s'en apercevrait stacy de
nos beaux lyon ça car j'ose à gaz ont
fait un peu trop que ça
je pense qu'il est temps d'y aller si
vous dites oh bwana mais voilà comme je
suis déterminé à passer le plus de temps
possible avec vous pendant les prochains
jours voilà une nouvelle formidable
petit déjeuner presse sam est libellé
qu'est ce je crois que je suis un peu
stressé à cause de la pression du
concours qui approche
[Musique]
allez lens elle est ce que ça va je veux
que vous surveiller de très près la
duchesse elle a l'air un peu différente
désolé je regrette elle ce n'était pas
très disney ça ne m'a pas déplu
noël est pour moi synonyme d'amour je
t'ai jamais vu ou ce sentiment peut-être
que tu ne me connais pas si
je pensais pas que les choses
deviendraient si compliqué alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr de pouvoir continuer
tout va bien ouais ça va très bien
[Musique]